unfortunately many women in our
community like Fox
who objects to that we like the bad boy
bad boy is different from the thug
that's and I think that's women yeah I
was going to say that's just gonna say
that I've got a rebuttal but carry on
say it say it it's gone I think that
someone in general is not just black
woman and I think also like age range
like you're not gonna say you're not
gonna ask a 40 year old woman if she
likes a thug by a 20 year old wood yes
the bad boys like differences
listen every woman wants a bad boy but
some women they want they want the
neurosurgeon who who's on point he could
also be the bad boy yeah he's a bad boy
they want Top Gun they want the they
want the fourth officer he's killing
what they want the Navy SEAL kill it
they're killing people they're shooting
people so it every woman wants a bad boy
but they're different so our bad boys
are different than the other ones yeah I
think I think it's more they just want
an alpha male yeah we want like a
protector
if you're the main doctor on the ward
like right you're not a bad boy but
you're the alpha like all the women in
that
the thing is if we can compare it by
Community to communities of women by
communities of women yeah their
perception has in our community
especially in the west maybe not so much
back home in our should like our home
countries but in the west where we are
polluted with all these kind of
different ideas and stereotypes like the
the black women in these communities
have a warped perception of what
masculinity is they see it as the drug
dealer the driller the Trap art bro
because it's reinforced over and over
and over and over and you've been
watching it from when you was little
above you know what I'm saying so that's
a hard thing to break out until all of a
sudden oh yeah you know what I need a
teacher
you've been you've been dating Jewelers
your whole life and now all of a sudden
you want to teach on about it and let's
say you even do that bro you're not
really you don't really get that same
adrenaline in Rush with him so you're
really not going to be happy you're
going to you're always going to feel
like you're sitting in unless this guy
is a super Tyrone you're gonna feel like
you're settling with that guy even if
you make six figures because a lot of
these girls talk about six figures but
these some six figures guys I've got
women that are still cheating on them so
that's not the that's that's why when
guys try to talk about oh yeah you have
to be this Rich RAV no you don't RAV
yeah it's probably about it and that
means what does that mean
I think about like the ideal partner I
always kind of paint a scenario in my
head off if there was to end tomorrow if
the world was to end tomorrow how would
me and you survive what are the skills
that you can bring to the table that I
don't have yeah how good and this is
probably you mean how will he keep you
alive no how that will keep each other
alive you're not gonna keep him alive if
it turns into Mad Max time yeah let me
let me be real with you if it turned
into Mad Max time yeah you'd be in
danger bro you're being serious danger
bro you need a guy to be your protector
that's what it boils down to probably
yeah and he goes That's what I'm saying
so that is no you said we will protect
no you're not no no survive because you
for me to for me to even be with you and
for you to be my protector we have to
even have good communication otherwise
you're going to be protecting me no you
need to be able to ready he needs to be
ready to murk anyone that comes to
attack you don't violate he needs to
it's not nah it is no it's not just that
because you don't just if the world was
to end tomorrow means that if it's just
me and him in the world at least be
strong enough to climb a tree if I can't
do it if he's strong enough to murk
people I'm sure he can climb a tree yeah
so I'm just saying it's not about
actually having to murk somebody it's
about survival I gave you a clear
scenario if we was in Mad Max times
where it's just wild just wild like
anything goes you're in serious danger
so I'll survive brother okay on my own
so for example let me explain doctor
here who says he's five foot seven and
everything like that I wouldn't be
looking at his skill to be able to keep
us surviving in the world and for him to
go climb a tree to beat somebody
somebody up but I do know that if
anything went wrong he'd be able to save
us he will know exactly which vein to
cut if anybody come to attack us is
about having skills that mean you you
ensure your survival goes a bit further
than the next person he's not all about
strength okay so okay in a real in a
real one yeah and I'm not I'm not
putting down what what you're saying I
agree with you but what I'm saying is
that okay On A Primitive level on a
straight
um basic level yeah is Mad Max type you
ever watched Mad Max
you have any of you ever watched It's
about The Purge no even The Purge let's
take it to the purge if it was Purge
time yeah they were just like oh let's
just Purge everyone can Purge no law bro
who's more in danger me or you you right
so you know it depends on who's this why
why are you more in danger than I am
because you're weaker than me okay
physically and this is what I'm trying
to explain as well just because we have
this conversation all the time
let's add context and let's add then
you're physically biologically I'm
faster than you and stronger than you
I've got more endurance I can go longer
than you okay what if I'm better at
maybe she's smarter than you yeah maybe
but let's talk about what we do know for
sure there's no point in talking about
maybes well but if you don't know for
sure that you'd be able to survive it
better than me
I'm being realistic I have a better
Fighting Chance than you do just by the
attack by what just by biology by
science yeah what kind of but not really
because he doesn't overly on your
physical
doctor here will be able to survive
quite well actually in The Purge because
all he's got to do is hide behind the
door and you'll be able to see this
person is coming I cut him on this thing
right on the bed at this very neck and
they'll pass out like that because he's
smart because he understands whereas you
be wanting to talk to me you don't know
that's not talking about oh that means
because I think I'm strong that means
I'm gonna punch I'm just saying a
fighting chance bro if you I think if
you was to ask a hundred people yeah who
would you rather want on your team in in
The Purge or protecting you in a purge
would you want someone that was more
physically capable straight up just like
Stronger Faster tougher can take more
pain blah blah blah or would you want
somebody who's less
like it's a straight question you
probably want somebody that is less
because we're more likely to go into
hiding you that is the big guy
good luck good luck you're gonna need it
I never said that because you're strong
you're going to be stupid and running
around with like a headless chicken I'm
just saying you've got a better Fighting
Chance but good luck to you in it and
your chicken anyway so
um
yeah
and I'm smart too no
anyway we got to a big T
for the super Chasers what are the
benefits of legal marriage that's not
the this is not the one that's another
day but big up to you my brother bigger
Daniel for the Super Chat he says to
White jumper
that's you uh a public video that King
reacted a while or or a while ago the
black women and even the Latina chicks
said they would prefer criminals and
scammers it's not cap oh that's true
yeah I remember dude I've done loads of
videos like reaction videos like that
where girls just flat out say they want
a scammer over what nine to five maybe
because he makes more money that's what
they care about just money is
yeah or maybe because the waiting
processes
on Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible